mooo how star Candace Cameron Bure has
one little girl who's all grown up and
now Natasha just took a big step forward
in her singing career joining team
Lavigne on the voice she stepped by ET
today to chat with ET on line so
pecially
and he'll fall ill in the
I was really hoping he would turn for
Mises it's very very surreal tell me how
did the opportunity to audition for the
Boise come to you I had gotten an email
a couple months before blind auditions
happened and I was not interested I'm
way too competitive that would just not
be good for me to be on a show like that
but my mom and my dad and my
grandparents were always like you should
try out you know it'd be so much fun
Natacha beret made her debut last night
with a reworked version of elvis
presley's can't help falling in love
and though she got a little nervous her
coach Adam Levine isn't worried I'm
really happy on my team welcome it's a
huge show it I was like wow this is
gonna be everywhere so it was very
nervous I was great he's given me a lot
of tips about just being in the zone and
singing with emotion and passion
Natasha's family was front and center
for her blind audition and she's turned
to her mama Candace Cameron Bure for
advice on handling the spotlight I've
kind of just learned from watching her
more than I have her telling me it you
know she worked as you know since she
was 5 years old
and she didn't kind of fall off the
wagon like a lot of other child stars
have which is just a great testament to
who she is